-Thank you for coming on.
-Thank you for having me.
What a thrill.
-You look great. Dude --
-Thank you.
Lilac for you tonight, Jimmy.
-You really did lilac for me.
And I love it.
Thank you so much.
But I also --
Dude, I'm loving the beard.
Are you gonna shave that off?
-I am -- At the moment I step
out of that theater in January.
I'm going to --
I'm going to trim it.
I'm not going to shave it all
because it's contour for men.
It gives me a nice, like --
No, you look great.
-I do like it. I wasn't able to
grow one for a really long time.
So now that I have one,
I might keep it
for a little while.
-I think you should.
It looks really good.
I just --
Sometimes you feel like
when you're forced
to have a beard
like you have to have
in "Sweeney Todd,"
you're like --
As soon as the play is done,
you're like,
"That's it. I'm shaving it."
-I actually kind of
had to pitch it
because, like,
a barber with a beard,
like, you're not selling much
if you're -- if you're --
-I guess. Yeah.
A barber with a beard.
No, but he wouldn't --
-Thought it looked cool.
Like, "Yeah, you can do that.
Sure."
-"Yeah." I want to show
a picture of you.
This was --
-Who's that baby?
-Yeah. Look at this baby here.
This is "Closer."
-Who's that kid? [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is the 20th anniversary?
-20th anniversary of that album.
Yeah, it was an album
that really changed my life.
And I can't believe the time
has flown. The song --
-20 years. Josh, that's crazy.
-I'm an old.
-No, you're not an old.
I'm an old.
But, I mean, this is wild.
November 17th, this comes out.
-This comes out.
And so many of the songs
on this album changed my life
and have been a part of
so many people's lives.
And when they write me letters,
they talk about a lot
of the songs on this album.
So we're putting it out
with some extra songs
and bonus stuff,
some studio stuff
that's not been released before.
-This was -- "You Raise Me Up"
was on this album?
-It was. Yeah. And --
-That was the biggest song.
-Oh, my.
Every wedding, every funeral.
-Yeah. Both. Yeah.
You had them both covered.
-And everything in between.
-No, but I remember
when that song came out,
it was like --
I saw it in places. I go --
Everyone loved it.
It was on commercials.
It was on everything. I go --
It was part of the, like --
I want to say the Olympics.
Was it a meaningful moment?
-It was omnipresent.
-Yes.
-It really was. Yeah.
I mean, it's such a lucky thing
when you have a song like that,
that has been everywhere,
and I remember the first time
I heard it in the back of
a taxi cab in Dublin, Ireland,
when I was promoting
my first album.
And then at some point somebody
came into the studio
with it and was like,
"Hey, I think you'd be
really right for that song."
I was like, "That was my drunken
Irish taxi cab song."
-Yeah.
-And we never expected it to be
a single, and it just blew up.
-I -- Congrats on that.
And, by the way, congrats
on the 20th anniversary
deluxe edition.
Pick this up. And it's got
some extra Easter eggs.
Got some Easter eggs in there
for fans.
-Yeah, it does. Definitely.
Yeah.
There's a verse
that we had cut out
of "You Raise Me Up" early on,
and we put it back in.
-Yes!
-Now it's 17 minutes longer.
-Yeah. Oh, my god. Fantastic.
So it's a quadruple album.
-That's right. It is. Yeah.
-But I was talking to you.
I was lucky enough to go
see you at "Sweeney Todd,"
but we were talking backstage.
"Sweeney Todd."
You crush this.
-Thank you.
-And you were saying to me
that you were kind of
a theater nerd.
-You were a theater kid.
Yeah. Still am.
Yeah, I --
You know, Sweeney Todd
is one of those iconic roles
that for those of us
that grew up,
you know,
with baritone voices
and just, you know, not really
having the ability to dance,
there were certain roles
that were like,
"Oh, I want to
dive into that one day."
And "Sweeney Todd"
is just one of the most
brilliant pieces of music
ever written.
I did it
when I was in summer camp
at Interlochen Arts Camp
in Michigan.
-No way.
-I was in the ensemble
and had the best time
of my life.
-And here you are on Broadway.
It's so full circle.
-Getting nominated
for a Tony Award.
Not too shabby, buddy.
-It's been really amazing.
Our cast and crew...
-Little Josh Groban.
If you're watching.
-Little Joshy.
-Little Joshy,
if you're watching,
you did pretty well, buddy.
-In another dimension somewhere.
-Yes. It might happen.
Who knows where this show airs.
-Who knows?
-I got to see it opening night.
-Yes, you did.
-Of course I was crying.
I was laughing.
Because it's very dramatic.
-We loved hearing you laugh.
Can I tell you -- on the stage,
we could hear you laughing
and we're like, "Jimmy's here!"
-Oh, did you hear it?
-Was I distracting?
-No, it wasn't distracting.
-It was so funny.
-We felt --
we felt the love out there,
and it was so, so awesome.
-Annaleigh Ashford
was unbelievable.
is incredible. Gaten Matarazzo.
I mean, this cast is so great,
and there is a lot
of dark humor in the show,
which not a lot of people
sometimes know
when they --
when they get the premise of --
-Oh, I was --
I thought it was well-directed.
It was so funny. Every time --
I mean, obviously,
if you don't know the story,
I'm gonna spoil it for you.
But he's a barber
and he kills people.
-He kills -- He dabbles.
He dabbles in killing.
-He dabbles in killing people,
and he uses the meat
they serve in meat pies
and sell it to everybody.
Anyway...
-This is after dinner, right?
-It's very -- Yes.
But when you --
You take 'em upstairs
to this barber chair,
and you slit their throats,
and then you pull the lever...
and the body goes out.
And I laughed every single time.
I go, "That's fantastic."
Except for --
Except for when the judge --
-Spoiler alert.
-Again, spoiler alert.
Whatever.
-But some people die,
and the chair is the coolest toy
because it is built --
It is a work of art.
This chair belongs in a museum
one day.
But it is also built like
an old antique, like, Winnebago.
Like, there's a clutch.
There's a lever.
It clanks. It's heavy.
-Do you have to,
like, press the thing?
-I have to press a thing and
pull a thing at the right time
so the hook goes into here.
-Then the body slides
down a slide, off the stage.
-Let me tell you --
they lube up the chair
pretty good before the show.
And so the actors just go way --
I mean, they are like, "Whee!"
And -- Sometimes I hear
a "whee" on the way down. Yeah.
And sometimes the chair --
Early on in previews,
the chair kind of decided
it was gonna be like,
"Hm, not today, Sweeney.
I'm not gonna do this today."
So the chair for a couple
of the early performances,
stopped working.
And that's, like,
my whole shtick in this show,
if you see it, like --
I finally get that chair
and I get to use the lever
and I get to do the thing.
So when the chair stopped
working, all of a sudden,
like, we had dead bodies
that were like...
[ Laughter ]
-Face-first down the slide.
-Crawling down
their own death hole.
-And then -- And then
they're also saying, "Whee."
-Yeah. "Whee!"
-You don't have to say "whee."
You're not going fast. Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Did the audience go with it?
-Yeah. Of course.
Because they knew
we were in previews,
and that's when stuff
is getting changed anyway.
But the audiences have been
right there with us.
And they do -- They laugh
when I send dead bodies.
Shame on you.
-No. No, no.
They're great. It's so good.
-No, it's very funny.
-The first song is
"The Ballad of Sweeney Todd,"
and it's just powerful
and loud and fun and great.
♪ The Ballad of Sweeney... ♪
-Yeah.
-People were singing.
It's unbelievable.
And then you come out,
and people go...
The show I was at.
And then I didn't get to hear
your first line.
-I know. It's so sad.
-Yeah.
-It's this epic opening number.
The whole ensemble stands
in a line in the front,
and the sopranos are just
singing these high D's,
and it's just -- it's amazing.
And I get pulled out
of the grave, and I've got my --
my big first line that --
I think we just finished
about 250 performances.
I don't think
anybody has ever heard
the first line that I have
in the show.
It's a good problem to have.
People are cheering.
But it's Sondheim.
You're not gonna vamp music
in a Sondheim show.
You're gonna sing it
exactly when it's written.
It's just
when people are clapping.
So usually people hear me
on the second line,
but not the first line.
-That's so unbelievable.
I was wondering --
I mean, since you're here
and we have a great audience...
We don't have to...
-We do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Jimmy, can I --
Can I sing
the first line of Sweeney --
of my entrance as Sweeney Todd?
-Can you please,
for the first time ever...
-For people who maybe
have been to the show
and have not heard
my first line as Sweeney Todd?
-Just the first line.
That's all I want to hear.
-Can I go center stage
and sing it with the Roots?
-Yes, you can!
-Oh, my God!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause stops ]
♪♪
-♪ Attend the tale
of Sweeney Todd ♪
-There he is!
That's what I'm talking about!
-Ohh! Thank you so much!
-Oh! Oh!
♪♪
-Absolutely.
Josh Groban, everybody!
Oh, my gosh, Josh.
You were amazing.
-Wow. Thank you so. much.
Thank you.
-Go see him in "Sweeney Todd"
on Broadway right now!